joining me now is new Gingrich former
speaker of the house and Fox News
contributor new um there have been a
number of concerns raised by how this
law fair as we just discussed in the
last segment with two former Supreme
Court clerks I made three of us about
how this is being used to shortcircuit
the electorate and yet and yet we have
we have Republicans even out there
saying oh well if this happens and we'll
move on as a country do you think that
all will be well if for some reason the
Supreme Court does not correct what was
done in
Colorado no I think this is a
potentially catastrophe um a, 360,000
coloradans voted for Donald Trump in the
last election four lawyers want to block
him from being on the ballot that means
uh basically for every
34,000 uh colar roddens who voted for
Trump one lawyer is stopping them that's
a system of establishment arrogance
that's not
sustainable uh and the last great effort
like this was the 10 states that refused
to put Abraham Lincoln on the ballot in
1860 uh the American people are not
going to tolerate and I hope the Supreme
Court fully understands this the
American people are not going to
tolerate being told that they're not
allowed to have a choice for who they
want to have as president this is not
Venezuela it's not Nicaragua it's not
Cuba and I think the Democrats are
dangerously close to causing the kind of
Confrontation that would be truly
disastrous for the
country now to that point um I want to
play something that the lieutenant
governor of Texas Dan Patrick floated on
our show last night new it got a lot of
attention watch seeing what happened in
Colorado makes me think except we
believe in democracy in Texas maybe we
should take Joe Biden off the ballot
inex Texas for allowing 8 million people
to cross the border since he's been
president n i mean look at what's
happened to America with this open
border I mean it it that in and of
itself is it's its own type of of
insurrection against sovereignty against
the rule of law so I mean is this not a
natural reaction if this is the
precedent they set yes look Biden's
illegal immigration policy which leads
to Biden's illegal immigrants is a
disaster and it's deliberate it's not
there's not a failure on the border
there's a deliberate policy on the
border to maximize the number of people
who come in the next stage will be for
the left to demand that they be allowed
to vote even though they're here
illegally uh you can see the whole
process and that's why we are I think
moving dangerously close to a really
genuine confrontation over the very
nature of America you've seen it on the
college campuses uh with the
anti-semitic out Uprising in favor of
terrorism uh and a realization that the
universities are wildly out of control
and teaching things that are just plain
crazy uh there is a point where the
average American is going to say this is
totally wrong I think what President
Biden said today is proof the people who
want to destroy democracy are the
Democrats ask Robert F Kennedy Jr who's
been blocked at every stage ask the
people from No Labels who've been fought
in every state uh the Democrat idea is
they get to win because no one else gets
to compete and I think that the average
American as they realize that the level
of anger at the Democratic party is
going to become
dramatic do you think n civil unrest is
a possibility here if this continues if
these types of attacks against Real the
Democratic process
continues well I think what what you
heard last night from the Texas
contingent tells you you know this is
still a country where states have
enormous levels of Freedom uh and if
we're going to get into a real knockdown
drag out fight uh you which would be
crazy let me let me emphasize where we
are right now what the Democrats are
doing right now is insane and is in
danger of tearing apart the whole
society but you could imagine a
circumstance in Hardline Republican
states where they have absolute control
of the legislature and of the
governorship there are probably 10 or 15
or 20 states that could strip the
Democrats off the ballot that would be
nuts it would be totally wrong uh but
that's what that's what they are setting
up is that what you now have is
basically a fascist Democratic party who
believe in government control government
domination and by the way in a number of
states like Michigan and California
they've passed laws strengthening the
governor's ability to have emergency
power which I think is very very
forboding given how much they abused it
in 2020 right well n uh these are these
are scary times but let's hope cooler
and more constitutional heads prevail
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else